[Music]
a few years ago a leading scientific
company had a specific challenge it was
a toothpaste company and they make
different fluorides for their toothpaste
but there was a big mechanical problem
the fluoride was getting stuck in the
equipment and it wasn't meshing well the
company had engaged all their top
chemists to try to figure out what the
problem was and no one could solve it it
was taking months and months and time
and costing hundreds of thousands of
dollars at that point so the executive
on the team said you know what we have
not been able to solve this who else
could we engage what other networks
could help us solve this problem so the
company ended up posting this fluoride
challenge on a website called
InnoCentive which is a community of
crowd-sourced scientists who come
together to help large companies solve
scientific challenges within a few days
of posting this fluoride challenge a
physicist who lived in Canada looked at
the problem online and said this isn't a
chemistry problem it's a physics problem
it's about charged particles you charge
the fluoride one way the toothpaste the
other instantly the problem was solved
Colgate realized a few things from this
experience the first thing is that they
never even dare to ask the physicist at
their own company because they had
labeled it as a chemistry problem the
other thing they realize is that
physicists that solved the problem may
have never been hired by Colgate he
didn't have the traditional resume he
had had different careers throughout his
life in so in today's world we can
access and engage expertise in a
radically different way to find
real-time solutions and those that may
have the answers are those that choose
to contribute they may not be who we
suspect are the right people to
contribute in my book get big things
done the power of connectional
intelligence my co-author sasha nicole
joan i and i distilled
connectional intelligence into five
specific traits we looked at companies
and leaders around the world and found
that there were specific skill sets that
you could use to build your own
connectional intelligence and they're
called the five seas of connectional
intelligence the first sea is
curiosity and we all think about
curiosity is the ability to ask great
questions but from a connectional
intelligence perspective curiosity is
the ability to design your questions so
that other networks outside of your own
can engage to help you solve those
problems so if you think about when
you're solving a problem today how can
you not only be curious to ask who you
traditionally go to but how might you
design your question to engage a new
community a different resource an
outside perspective from another company
or even outside your industry that could
lead to a new and different breakthrough
solution the second C of connectional
intelligence is combination in
combination as we all know is the root
of innovation combining disparate ideas
people and resources to come up with
something entirely new and different so
as you think about combination how are
you leveraging your combination skills
of different resources within your
company across teams across business
units at different levels in different
regions of the organization and far
beyond with companies and customers and
other stakeholders that could help
create and forge new business solutions
new opportunities and address challenges
that you may be facing the third C of
connectional intelligence is courage and
we all know that courage is such a key
part of all of all of the key ways of
connecting and when I define courage
from a connectional intelligence
perspective it's really the ability to
be able to have difficult in different
types of conversations but not just
raise those conversations being willing
to amplify and sustain them over time
because we know that having a one-time
connection doesn't create breakthroughs
it's those people that are willing to be
courageous to continue those
conversations over time often it could
take years to really lead to that
breakthrough but it's that sustaining of
the courageous conversation that creates
that so as you think about your own
courage
how many courageous conversations are
you having every day
are you sustaining those conversations
over time
and what might be those forms are
avenues that would allow you to amplify
your own courage who do you surround
yourself with and make connections with
that makes you courageous yourself the
fourth C of connectional intelligence is
community and we all know that community
is such a big aspect of this finding
different networks of people that can
care about similar things that can spark
ideas together and what we found with
connectional intelligence is those that
really tap into this super power are
those that see communities far beyond
traditional forums far beyond the
traditional hierarchies so it could be a
community of moms in the company at
Unilever that have a new way of thinking
about what their customers might need or
it could be a network of Latino
employees at frito-lay who realize that
there's an opportunity for a guacamole
Doritos chip that turned into a hundred
million dollar product for the business
so communities can be far beyond our
traditional spectrums of what people's
roles and traditional sources of
expertise are so as you think about your
own communities what communities are you
involved with what informal formal
communities what internal and external
communities do you engage with and how
might you be able to leverage them not
just for what they're traditionally
known for but what other problems they
could solve for you for your team your
company and Beyond and the last sea of
connectional intelligence is combustion
so once you have courage curiosity
community combination it's about how do
you allow it to mobilize and combust
combustion is the ability to mobilize
and curate your communities to create
added value so it's when you've built
your community it's when you've tapped
into the courage of that community that
allows those people to create value in a
new and different way
you